Andrew, Tim,
congratulations, you've
made it into the final
round of this competition.
So now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic weapon
from history, the shamshir.
Descending from the
saber family of swords,
the shamshir, which means
curved like the tiger's tail,
first gained
popularity in Persia
and quickly spread throughout
the former Ottoman Empire.
Light in weight
and easy to wield,
this deeply curved sword
featured a thin blade
and a tapered tip that was
most effective when delivering
sweeping or hooking strokes.
It was sharp enough to
slice adversaries in two.
Although use of the sword
declined in the 20th century,
it was rebirthed as
one of the main weapons
of the protagonist in the
film, "Prince of Persia--
The Sands of Time."
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Good luck, Tim.
[music playing]
ANDREW: I'm very excited to
be back to my home forge.
I'm going to do a low layer,
random-pattered Damascus blade.
I feel that the judges will
appreciate the extra effort.
Ideally, I would like
to have my billet welded
up as quickly as possible.
But the Damascus is
taking a little bit
longer than I expected.
So I might be a
little bit behind.
But I think it'll set my
blade apart from Tim's.
TIM: We're here in my home
shop in Angier, North Carolina.
The first blade of this
length that I've ever done
with such a major curve in it.
And it's a hot day.
[laughs] I've forged probably
98% of what I do on the power
hammer.
But I keep hearing this hiss.
[hisses]
And I said, hmm,
something is not right.
Anytime you see smoke on a
compressor, that's not good.
We're in trouble.
Without the air compressor,
I can't use my power hammer.
It's all going to be by hand.
So this is going to be fun.
ANDREW: Yesterday, I spent most
of my time shaping the blade.
Today, I need to
pick up the pace.
It's ready for heat treatment.
That's what you're looking for.
In order for me to be happy
at the end of the day,
I'm going to have to have my
guard forged, shaped, polished,
and fit to my [inaudible].
[bleep]
Definitely have a lot of
struggles with this guard.
I was looking really good, but
I got off center with my cut.
And I broke the langet off.
I just wanted to throw [bleep].
I spent most of the day
working on this guard,
so it's disheartening.
I need to just step back
and rethink my plan.
TIM: Three days in, little sore.
It's been over the anvil
for five hours straight.
I'm old.
[laughs] Never done
anything this long.
So this is maiden voyage
for my quench tank.
We're leaking.
And all my oil was just--
like a little geyser
coming out of there.
Lucky for me, I do have
a horizontal quench tank.
I see a bow here
and a bow there.
One going this way, and one
going back the other way.
I gotta move quick.
So I slap it in my
straightening jig.
Bottom line, this is a mess.
Can't go back now.
I don't know what
I'm going to do.
I'm almost afraid to look.
We are straight.
I took a file.
[laughs] Oh, I'm just
tickled to death.
I still got a lot
of work ahead of me.
I'm not 100% happy with
what I've got with my guard.
But if I do a nice job on
the blade and the handle,
I think it'll bring
it all together.
But I got a slight
warp in the blade.
If we put this on
here, you can see
where the warp is, fuses
follow the straight edge,
you have that gap right there.
I got to get this
warp out, so what
I'm doing is using a couple
clamps and a little jig
I have made in the temper
to try to take it out.
This is normally how I get
the warp out of my blades,
but I'm having more
trouble this time.
So I'm just going
to put a little bit
more tension on the blade,
and maybe that'll work.
I go back to the
heat treat oven,
and I didn't get the
warp out entirely,
and I'm starting to
freak out a little bit.
I don't know how
I'm going to fix it.
Final day, I am exhausted.
Right now, I'm going
to do some chopping.
It's fantastic.
I know I've got a sword
that will perform.
Now it's just getting
the look down.
This is all about how
it feels in the hand.
One thing I always do when I
make a handle, I grind a bit,
I put it in my hand, I close my
eyes, I don't even look at it.
Light grip, squeeze it hard.
Overall, I feel fantastic.
I'm very confident that
it's a $10,000 blade.
To test the sharpness
of your weapon,
I'll be cutting through
these three fish.
Andrew, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Here goes nothing.
Yes.
Nice.
All right.
So first thing, it's
not a light sword.
But the weight's
where I want it to be.
Beautiful-looking handle.
Having said that, up here at
the front, it's a little blocky.
But it's definitely sharp.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, Tim.
You ready for this?
I'm ready.
This blade is
wonderfully fast and light.
Your handle, I like
the construction of it.
What I have a problem
with is this transition.
The two materials, it
creates a bit of a lip.
If that wrap went
all the way down,
I think it would
feel pretty good.
Having said that, this
is a beautiful piece,
and it is definitely a cutter.
Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: To see
what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do, I
will take your shamshir
and deliver slashes in a
thrust of these pig carcasses.
Andrew, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
Andrew, your shamshir
just became a sham-wow.
Your blade on the initial
thrust penetrated easily,
and it lacerated cleanly
into the carcass.
Your weapon, sir, will KEAL.
Good job.
Thank you.
Tim, it's your turn.
Shall we have fun?
Let's do it.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
All right, Tim.
This is what a shamshir, I
believe, should feel like.
It definitely can
thrust into the carcass.
It hit bone.
I felt it, I could
feel it crunch.
The edge here is sharp enough
to lacerate through the carcass,
cutting all the way through.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Thank you.
Now, the shamshir was
a weapon that was used
both on foot and on horseback.
So to test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'm going to chop into these
horse skulls three times.
Andrew, are you ready for this?
I guess.
So right off, I can
feel a slight rolled
section where the edge
is just deformed a bit.
But other than that,
held up beautifully.
Well done.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: [laughs]
Good smile, Tim.
It's your turn.
Let's go.
OK, I can see
where your edge is
taking some deformation here.
It's light and it's fast.
But it looks to me
as though your blades
picked up a slight roll that
way that I did not see before.
Your blade goes off
at a bit of an angle.
Bladesmiths, a final
decision has been made.
Only one of you can be the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is Andrew.
Congratulations, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Yes.
WIL WILLIS: Tim, please
surrender your weapon.
Obviously, I'm a
little disappointed.
I wanted to win, but I'm
very proud of the shamshir
that I made.
I enjoyed the
competition immensely.
It's been one of the
highlights of my life.
WIL WILLIS: Andrew,
congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Yes.
I definitely feel relieved.
It feels great.
I mean, I came here to win
and prove to myself that I was
able to do it, and I can hang
with these other guys with
their credentials and whatnot.
I don't have any of that, I'm
just a guy from the woods,
you know?